[Music]
we'll break it down slowly a big hour
tonight the corrupt Trump hating news
media they are dusting off the tinfoil
hats fuelling up their black helicopters
and are running absolutely wild with
baseless conspiracy theories about
president Trump and his great health
report we're going to cover the
out-of-control media and this bias we do
it regularly on the program but this is
now insane this is a new level
so dr. Ronnie Jackson he briefed the
media on the results of the president's
extensive medical exams what did he find
a president in excellent health
dr. Jackson is also saying the president
and he did so well in a cognitive test
and he has normal perfect neurological
functions no early onset on Alzheimer's
or dementia now of course it did not fit
the media and their preconceived fake
news narrative the President Trump is
crazy suffering from dementia early
onset and is mentally unfit to serve
which means in their twisted minds he
needs to be thrown out of office for 49
long minutes the media breathlessly
hysterically asking the president's
doctor about his mental fitness they
couldn't believe the answers they were
getting he asked for the cognitive test
it's one of the best tests out there and
he passed it perfectly 30 out of 30 this
is something they have been obsessing
over you're gonna enjoy this watch can
you assess the president's mental
fitness for office the president
appeared to slur his words I'll give you
an address did you look into what the
cause of that might have been at all are
you ruling out things like early onset
Alzheimer's are you looking at
dementia-like symptoms on what basis
would you and this is just a
philosophical question advise the
cabinet that the president is unable to
discharge his duties how does that
market met when you analyze his
cognitive ability or do a lot of neural
aaja chol functions that is not the same
thing as a psychiatric exam or
psychological it's not you mentioned the
president a cognitive test was that the
mini-mental State Examination or the
post assessment if not can you tell us
what specific cognitive test either was
a given that there is scrutiny of what
was overlooked at the time with
President Reagan in terms of Alzheimer's
and things he was been known to suffer
from at a later date can you say that
whether the tests that you ran would
exclude any of those things humans age
in continuing his physicals in the
future will you also continue the
cognitive testing you say that the
president was the one who requested the
cognitive test that it wasn't
necessarily needed for someone of his
age did you if he tell you why he wanted
it done what is your take of all the
doctors and clinicians all across the
country who have said in this president
they see symptoms of this symptoms
symptoms of dementia pretty amazing now
to reiterate dr. Jackson he told the
media that the president is in excellent
health and he could easily serve for two
terms that really got to them now the
only thing wrong okay he has moderately
high cholesterol a lot of us do he needs
to lose a couple of pounds a lot of us
do and of course the media they couldn't
stand the good news they couldn't even
believe it now this is what's
interesting they have so convinced
themselves in their little bubble that
they have you know it's like an echo
chamber that only they listen to endless
hours of speculation that the president
was unfit for office so the press
conference just continued to go off the
rails like I have never seen before
never before as a doctor been this
transparent with the media asking dr.
Jackson about things like the
president's Twitter use his television
watching habits how many scoops of ice
cream he has for dessert take a look at
what supposedly is investigative
journalism in this country in action
take a look do you keep a tally of how
much gold the US president plays some of
the president's friends have told
reporters in the past they think he's a
germaphobe that he washed his hands
obsessively and is concerned about that
do you see any indication of
the behavior do you see any evidence of
bone spurs which the president said that
we suffered from which we limited to one
scoop of ice cream now
yeah Twitter doesn't involve me as a
doctor I don't I don't I don't have any
concern on that does the president wear
dentures the president has no partial
ordnance of any kind he has no drug
addiction we have a lot of people in the
studio tonight they're all laughing all
right we actually went back and we
checked to see if the media ever asked
anything close to those kind of
questions about Barack Obama's health or
any other president for that matter and
the answer of course they did not
now after that frenzied display members
of the media they should have their own
heads examined look I've said this
before
hating Trump is their heroin it's their
drug and they're completely hooked on
their drug they're like addicts the only
thing that gives them their fix is
attacking the president minute by minute
and the media is so completely utterly
unhinged and deranged in today's press
conference is just the latest episode
ever since President Trump announced his
candidacy you have the blind sheep in
the liberal media who live in their own
little bubble and bounce their own
recycled talking points in their own
little echo chamber
they've been rushing to create a new
crisis after a new crisis after new
crisis and the recent hyperventilation
has reached extreme levels even for
their pathetically low standards by the
way it's one crisis one panic one total
meltdown after another where they repeat
the exact same words meaning NBC ABC CBS
and there are times Washington Post they
used the same commentary until something
better can be blown out of proportion
comes along and for the last couple of
weeks let's see the media schizophrenia
has been on full display
it's gone from a year of saying
President Trump colluded with Russians
there's no evidence the President Trump
is going to start a nuclear war they're
not mad that it was in fact Bill Clinton
that gave North Korea billions and
promised it's gonna be a good day of
American people so the media being BFFs
with Steve Bannon
you know they were friends for at least
three days because he made comments that
they liked for once and then giddiness
over bannon's comments and Michael
Wolf's phony book
now this is the narrative that now it's
Trump's crazy
we should invoke the 25th amendment
we'll use that to throw them out of
office Russia didn't work take a look at
this insane coverage that you're getting
and I tell you media's dead I told you
in 2007 I was more right than I ever
dreamed take a look we want to start
with this week in Russia gate this cloud
about collusion with Russia will hang
over him no matter where he stands
Donald Trump is afraid a political
hurricane is out there at sea for him
we'll call it hurricane Vladimir if you
will the whole Russian thing this is
evidence of willingness to commit
collusion there's outright treason I
mean there is no question that what he
is doing is giving aid and comfort to
the enemy the idea of a nuclear showdown
with North Korea keeps you up at night I
would recommend deleting your Twitter
app this is a language that would have
been rejected from the script of dr.
Strangelove we can't begin to normalize
this this is dangerous this is childish
this is unpresidential it's not
befitting the leader of the free world
perhaps never have we seen a man whose
profound sexual and masculine
insecurities are literally threatening
to annihilate the planet he is not
merely being cavalier with a threat
about nuclear war he's being Cavalier in
a way that it makes him seem demented
these are the messages from a person who
is not well from a leader who is not fit
for office none of this normal
none of this acceptable none of this
frankly stable behavior return now to
the public rift that broke out today
between president Trump and his former
chief strategist Steve Benin but if
Bannon and Trump are getting divorced
who gets what this is certainly Trump's
kind of bye Felicia moment for banning
wait
dr. humpty-dumpty and dr. Anderson
Cooper and dr. Nicole Wallace this is
hard to keep up with you see if you
watch really closely this is how they do
it this is interesting
one person will say in their bubble he's
really demented no he's really really
demented and then the next liberals say
no really really really demented and
they're talking to themselves get how
they need their own examination there's
a reason the American people don't watch
a lot of these fake news networks now
after moving on from these manufactured
crises one after another the media's new
drug of choice is the alleged comments
the president Trump made in a heated
Oval Office debate about immigration
fake news CNN loses it they need some
help they need some psychiatric help
and according to the media Research
Center the network literally said on
their Shull I'm not allowed to say it
I'll be honest I'd say it not allowed
195 times on Friday alone
take a look what was your reaction when
you heard the president called you know
African nations polls it's not clear
what he meant by all countries are you
shocked or surprised by this I'm not
surprised
in one way I'm proud I am a proud older
no we are not all created equal
at least not if you were born in as the
president put it a whole country the
word house instead of whole as in house
countries not whole countries I guess
he's bowler is there a difference if the
president said whole house do you think
these countries are polls Donald Trump
has turned the Oval Office it's rhabdo
bowlers built this country 110 years ago
in addition of the president comments
yesterday right a few more poll
countries pull-pull-pull country rich do
you have an example of any bold country
that the president referred to that is
predominantly Caucasian polish poles
polish oh I work for polar oh I'm proud
to be a polar ever a million years on I
would be saying all on television what a
haul fake into his Network now I wonder
if the CEO will soon to be
scandal-plagued Jeff Zucker and a
stenographer Humpty Dumpty a really
proud of that coverage it's pretty
pathetic maybe I need to do a public
service maybe I need to send CNN over a
case of xanax if I can get it legally
and since the media led by the highly
esteemed doctors joe scarborough and
assumed to be bribed dr. micha Burzynski
since they love to diagnose the
president even though they have zero
medical
qualifications alright let me play the
same game I'll step into their echo
chamber for a minute
and I'll play their game here's dr.
Hannity's prescription tonight all of
you who in the fake news network you
desperately trust me
need psychiatric help you are all out of
touch with reality and suffering from
delusional group think about the
president and if for some reason you
overpaid lazy so-called journalists
can't pay for it I'll help you because
I'm probably paid more and I'll offer
assistance and also tonight everything
that we have been telling you let's get
serious for a minute is now starting to
play out this is the serious side they
don't talk about forgotten men and women
and by the way this isn't about me being
right to show being right even though we
are clearly the team that we have
assembled here the only ones in the
media talking about it it's about what's
right for the country it's about our
Constitution this is what's serious
about it what's right for the rule of
law equal justice under the law we have
been uncovering I'm peeling the layers
of that onion the clinton bought and
paid for fake news Russian propaganda
dossier it is now being exposed and
there's so much more to come we're
learning the dossier was used by the
Obama administration to literally spy
and get that FISA warrant on members of
the Trump campaign and a president-elect
this is serious they've weaponized
America's most powerful tools of
intelligence to go after an opposition
party in an election year and then of
course a president-elect we have a
massive development tonight in the
Clinton email server scandal Washington
Examiner reporting that the chief of
staff and senior counsel to the FBI
director Christopher ray is in fact will
be grilled by House lawmakers about the
corrupt Clinton email investigation oh I
thought that was dead and that's huge
because rebecky is the one that's going
to be grilled was one of three people
that James Comey sent his original
statement that exonerated Clinton Oh
before they investigated and 17 other
witnesses and Hillary Clinton hadn't
even been interviewed for how do you
write an exoneration before
investigating yeah this is serious the
same statement where Comey and his
minions changed the word twice from the
legal standard gross negligence which
would mean Hillary Clinton broke the law
and actually put in there that yeah
foreign entities got ahold of this and
then they changed it to extreme
carelessness and they used as a
justification all of this to let Clinton
walk free we know she committed felonies
that's serious if we have equal justice
under the law and then call me and his
little minions also altered the original
conclusion it was reasonably likely the
Clinton's server stored in the bathroom
of a mom and pop shop closet was hacked
by hostile actors top-secret classified
special access program information all
hacked and yet the fix is in before they
investigate and now we're learning more
and more about how top officials at the
FBI covered up evidence that Hillary
Clinton committed crimes and put our
national security your national security
at risk and just like with everything
else we have been telling you that the
media ignores it is only the start of
much bigger things that will be coming I
promise you this will rival the worst
scandals by far in American history
it's that severe and there's other
breaking news tonight Sarah Carter
reporting the fusion GPS you know the
firm that Clinton bought and paid for
the fake news Russian dossier that was
used to get the FISA warrant to dig up
dirt on the president Trump candidate
Trump well what is unclear is who was
paying for it now we know Hillary
Clinton the DNC she controlled shelled
out 12 million dollars to fund fusion
gps to pay for those Russian lies they
wanted to influence the election after
all they stole the primary from poor
Bernie and his supporters and sources
are telling me tonight that if the
information is about the dossier if it's
related to the public is what I was told
it will shock the conscience of
law-abiding Americans in the entire
country
that's how serious it is as the media
makes fools of themselves every night
and we're hoping that you the American
people that we you will get to see
everything because I am told when you do
it will blow you away
the real Russian scandal will finally be
exposed